[Music]
in free advertising news submitted by
Maximus a dad is asking for a refund of
his daughter's tuition fees after she
gets a tattoo of her school's Logan
Logan Logan the school's Logan [ __ ] it's
Logan you forgot to ask in front of
slogans Logan she's a little slow today
little slogan I'm a little light get it
[ __ ] cuz I forgot the S oh oh I thought
you meant Glatt like gluttonous I think
this does I know you're not [ __ ] that
I didn't do you it's only funny to make
fun of you because you're not a [ __ ] and
then like we like to call you that cuz
it's like you're really not look like it
if I didn't know you I would think that
right like I would pass for it yeah
absolutely
mostly when you have dancing titties
yeah yeah behaviorally I would believe
it but really the more you know somebody
the it gets for them I know a lie always
in for such a surprise when they get to
know who you are they'll be like oh my
god they see me in person like how the
[ __ ] sucks
she's not gonna blow me right off the
bat yes sorry boys alright so this story
here a BBC Antiques
I love BBC news channel this vicious
rumor are you calling her a slot the
award-winning Channel Jill hold Doctor
Who and many other famous series so he's
the star of the show
BBC's antiques road trip his name is
David he's 52 years old he's saying that
he paid for his daughter Hedy who's 23
Oh her name is Eddie
it was Hedy that should have been your
name oh my god I know I'm so sorry [ __ ]
I did it again on site after Hedy
McGrath may be the queen of Australia h
ET TI o Eddie you know yeah I mean
that's how I just pronounced it I
thought I was like Lena Headey like
Cersei Lannister mm-hmm without a name
oh that would have been funny yeah sound
though it would you pronounce it with h
ET t ET pet say what I'm American
this is maybe saying you gotta you gotta
commit to Nate okay yeah Hetty
so she's 23 she went on to form a punk
band and so in true Punk fashion she
ended up getting her school slogan test
that's use of the West that a [ __ ]
Punk fashion poem tattoos are the worst
tattoos musics the worst music - Jesus
she loves puppies really Mickey loves it
- and I'm always like oh what's up punk
tattoo like little nuts cool [ __ ]
that's for sure but it's always a great
government anarchy but it looks like the
Avengers now I've never seen a punk with
a fully done sleeve it's always just
like one here cuz it gets fully done
it's not punk anymore either
you have to go against the grain on
everything constantly against the grain
that's they try to be significant by
always being like edge Lords music but
if you're fully edgy they're not Punk
either yeah because if you try too hard
to be too edgy he's got to not care
about anything you're not being edgy
though you just said you like punk music
you're supposed to hate punk music now
oh if you like punk music you're
supposed to hate it oh you have to hate
what you like every time person I might
got a tattoo of some like insignificant
[ __ ] that happened in their life like I
smoked a cigarette once and now he has
like a cigarette tattooed on his knee
that's pretty punky shittily done
there's always one if you get a tattoo
of your [ __ ] on your [ __ ] is that
pretty pot that's next-level punk you
should start that baby I will Punk a
core I think metal punk it's too
hardcore
alright so her tattoo reads parvis and
butis
ten abyss grandia jutice which means
when you're steeped in little things you
shall safely attempt great things
okay so cool things so it's cool to be
petty my brows first holy [ __ ]
Jesus our band it looks pretty Punk
which I like the name of her band what
is it Tiffany twisted
so that's a cool name first part sure
yeah yeah
um so anyway so her now that she's in a
band and stuff like the dad is saying
that she's like a walking free
advertisement for the school because
it's the school slogan nobody looks at
that and says you should survey the
students and see how many know the
actual listen college tuition so nuts
this guy's got to look for deals
anywhere he can well it was for her
entire schooling so since she was in
kindergarten up until she cried oh [ __ ]
private school yeah
so the tuition fees costs about fifteen
thousand British pounds a year Wow so
he's like can I get some of it back
honestly the way I read this story like
he's joking yeah obviously so yeah I
think he's joking but um so he didn't
not really if he could get it though I'd
[ __ ] be like good for you this is
what he said um I've asked a Bernard
Castle school would be happy to refund
some of the school's fees I paid because
my daughter has tattooed the old school
motto across her chest it was a bit of a
shock to me and her mother after I
freaked out at the sight of the tattoo I
was furious that after all the money I'd
spent on her education I really didn't
expect her to end up being a free
walking advert for the school however a
little later I had the brilliant idea to
ask the school if they effectively like
to sponsor ahead petit in her music
career and give me back some of the
school fees I paid and what did the
school say if he was joking awesome if
he was serious I would laugh so hard and
like I'm not responsible for your
daughter's decisions but what if he's
serious and then they agree and they're
like wow good point we even thought
about that's what good Jean and he put
his money in the right place cuz I mean
she left with the right that's exactly
what I was gonna say because yeah
because exactly because she she was
classically trained just trained as a
singer and she even became the head of
choir oh why did the head
Hettie Hettie Hettie a lawyer yes and
then that's what she ended up forming
her own band the twisted Tiffany so
Tiffany twisted that wasn't it would
have been yeah
twisted Tiffany's and if the school does
give the money back then that means
she's actually available for sponsorship
so you could buy more ad space
shoulders face she has like chick-fil-a
on her show yeah like that'll be cool to
their cars yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's an app that you can sign up to
put your cars and add wherever I was
broke at a time I was thinking about it
why do you make money I didn't pay you
like the bigger the logo they Mort the
more they pay you and the more you drive
the more they pay you the more the
bigger the [ __ ] can of Red Bull on
top of your car than whether I seen a
lot of those man I would love to see
about your giant truck they'll be
amazing giant Red Bull mm-hmm
do it you should do it get the biggest
one possible make make it tough on your
truck to move that you'll put it on top
that's the best [ __ ] is when the trucks
looking like God Jesus the whole thing a
Red Bull that's good too let's go in
this low make it an aerodynamic
nightmare too when wind hits that thing
you're like worried sweating while
you're driving little bit the person
behind you should be like home no they
should be like this when they get behind
you real red ball in it too so as I'm
driving it shaking it Betty and
everything dude red balls of [ __ ]
expensive if you if you're a Red Bull
exported in the middle of freeway
everyone know but if you did explore to
the middle of a freeway you're Red Bull
can exploded everyone will pull over and
start [ __ ] scooping it up [ __ ] it I'd
be stupid into the chute and it drinking
it I'm like honey take this you put it
in the car put it the [ __ ] car
oh my give me something else are you a
monster use it no cuz that [ __ ] so
expensive I would drink redbull more but
it's so [ __ ] expensive I can't
justify it you like to taste better I
love the taste it's way better
do you like the sugar free or in the
regular sugar you always yeah don't [ __ ]
with the ocean but what about the white
monster I'm healthy that tastes pretty
good the white Moss is really good but
but it's nice no Red Bull Red Bull
standard Red Bull much better
very nice Michelin star if you will so
this is a dad at his CBC show
he looks so British it's awesome thank
what is that it's a head I mean have you
ever seen an item though when you're
just like I gotta have that [ __ ] like
you know people that collect antiques
and all that they they're just I gotta
have it and they spend like thousands of
[ __ ] dollars on just things that sit
around there um a dime from 1800 sold
for more than 1 million dollars Wow like
a dime just so you could stand there put
it under glass and look at her like yeah
look at that
well there's coins electors so I get
that I I don't even get that I don't get
it because some people I don't know they
really look alike those quarters when
they first came out the drummer boy once
mm oh maybe the state ones that won the
state one or you can make money off with
Haven did that but even then I still
don't get it I get to Jesus toasting the
Jesus toes cheeto you're seeing the
[ __ ] prophet meetings on bread like
that's incredible cheese or you know
maybe senior boy stur crackers or
something just preserve it yeah laminate
the bread yeah you got you got to cover
it in that laminate stuff imagine all
the kids I found out that this girl got
money if she were to get money from him
then everyone's gonna get that tattoo
cuz it's not a bad tattoo like it's a
[ __ ] cool Latin yeah I thought it was
gonna be like their school logo and like
their yeah yeah he's saying that his
daughter gets stopped all the time and
they ask her who are eyebrow lady's alma
mater alma mater mater so it's like
mater Tom mater excuse me who's your I
about lady your eyebrows are equivalent
to his glass they both got thick ass
eyebrows dollar bro that's crazy
well I like their here she you yeah all
right yeah I like her here yeah so would
you guys get your school logo and all
that tattoo
at the school I'll go to add it on them
yeah you don't - uh yeah UCLA yeah he
went to UCLA and then got UCLA the
[ __ ] animated bear sounds so familiar
yeah
was the logo I mean there I think that
slogan but I just said logo Logan I know
because I I never I never had school
spirit so I don't know what that's like
but I get it if you're like an athlete
like if you're a football player at a
big college or whatever and just I mean
like that's life you know or if it you
have to change your life in some way I
know there's a lot of military people I
get military tattoos I guess it's the
kind of the same thing if school changes
during a certain way oh that makes sense
speaking of tattoos we got our faces on
people's bodies oh that's right you both
they did this person checked out yeah
that was really he's saying that he just
uses our faces as a reference and he's
working his way through Jake hey girls
mm-hmm um like you ready yeah that's
tight wait all the girls are gonna be
tattooed lonely working on it in is he's
doing it on other clients yeah so the
clients don't even know they're just
like we have to approve it yeah well I
mean it's a reference for her face and
then he decorates however like hers was
a school you know here's my guys so much
you're what's up yeah I don't think
people had two guys on them very much
you don't want a picture Casey on your
thigh or nothing I want to be in like a
Danny Trejo tattoo I'm wearing asan bro
with like two revolvers like on
someone's chest that'd be cool
no that's a girl with a gun on his chest
that's Barry somebody she'd a tattoo of
me drinking the world's biggest can't
read book that's punk rock rock
[Music]
[Music]